shot to fame fighting corruption but on
Friday morning Satya moto resigned as
Brazil's justice minister on live
television he accused president Jed bull
Senado of political meddling in matters
of law enforcement when he fired federal
police chief Modi Silverlake so the day
before unfortunately there's no way for
me to fulfill the commitment I made if
I'm not able to do my job if I'm not
able to preserve the autonomy of the
federal police to carry out its work
Sergio Moro is considered by many as a
sort of anti-corruption Crusader and a
superstar among president je bolson
Otto's cabinet in 2014
moto a federal judge at the time was
appointed to the biggest political
corruption investigation in Brazil's
history a case that led to the arrests
of hundreds of politicians and business
elites the investigation codenamed car
wash would also lead to the fall of
Brazilian President Dilma Rousseff and
the arrest of former Brazilian President
Luiz inácio Lula da Silva prior to his
resignation
Sergio Moto's role as Brazilian justice
minister was seen by many as almost
symbolic some political analysts believe
Satya Moto's departure could have the
effect of dramatically eroding jayate
bowls inaros
already dwindling support base this this
shake had out the political structure in
Brazil in this exact moment the
politicians the political analysts the
markets are ow I aren't everything
freaking out about this resignation
because Sara Moore was one of the main
pillars of most onerous government in
terms of popularity and the fight
against corruption Brazil is really
really strong for the Brazilian for a
huge sector of Brazilian society and
they lost their yield she would sue
ellen's on Friday president poll senado
defended himself against the accusations
made by his outgoing minister mil
compliment the odds my commitment is to
the truth without distortions
it is not true that I wanted to know
about investigations
in the almost 16 months in which he was
in charge of the Minister of Justice mr.
Sergio Mora knows that I never saw him
to interfere in the investigation that
were being carried out
Sergio Matos resignation comes just over
a week after president bowl senado fired
his health minister recently c'mon detta
signalling there could be more political
turmoil still to come obrigada thoughts
have been abrazo below al jazeera